it started like a routine business trip
and
ended in china's secret detention system
stanley wong was crossing the border to
mainland china
when he was stopped border police
searched his phone and questioned him
for several
hours then
in the evening two police officers came
they handcuffed me and put a black hood
on my head
then they took me away
for fear of retribution we cannot show
his face
stanley wong is not his real name his
accounts cannot be verified
independently
but his story is in line with accounts
from other detainees
at that time border police had begun
systematically researching the phones of
hong kongers
crossing the border between hong kong
and the mainland
a photo of wong attending a peaceful
march in june
caught their attention he explained it
was an authorized march and that hong
kong's laws allowed him to participate
but they wouldn't listen
they said this was about a matter of
national security
and that it wasn't up to me to decide
what endangering it means
national security is above all other
laws when national security is concerned
they said
we can catch you in hong kong or any
other place in the world
huang was held in a single cell that had
been covered in soft material
the glass door was translucent from the
outside only
lights left permanently on over and over
they interrogated him
asking about photos on his phone and
contacts to foreign nationals
i had to crouch like this for the whole
duration of the interrogation
they placed me right under an air
conditioner with the wind blowing at me
constantly
each interrogation lasted a few hours
and whenever they thought i didn't sit
well
they would beat me like this
punch my back or kick me in the legs
the number of people who've been
detained at the border remains unknown
wong says he was able to catch glimpses
into other cells
that helped people whom he believes were
fellow hong kongers caught at the border
after 36 hours he was released
my family tried to ask the public
security where i was
but they just wouldn't say anything the
police even denied they knew me
and that i had crossed the border i
understood that i could easily be
disappeared anytime
he's dealt with the experience quite
well he says
and he won't let it stop him but now
when he crosses a border
his heart starts to beat a little faster
let's bring in the reporter now who
filed that for sdws matthias
berlinga joining us from beijing good
day to you
matthias matthias is there any way to
know
how widespread this violent form of
intimidation
is right now
it's very hard to say what we know is
that especially
in august there was a campaign to
intimidate hong kongers
at the border by searching their phones
and questioning them
most people were stopped at the border
they were questioned at the border
and then let go after a few hours these
cases
like the mans that we just saw
where people were taken away into uh
secret prisons or or interrogation
facilities uh are much rarer what we
know
is for of course the case of one
british consulate employee simon chung
who was held there for 15 days
and who has just given an account of
torture
that was much worse uh than what our man
here
describes okay so we're not only talking
about
torture though we're also talking about
as stanley
wong expressed one of his fears of being
disappeared
now now what is being disappeared and
how much
of a threat is that for hong kong
protesters
well people can be disappeared in china
at any time
they will be taken into some facilities
that are especially run
we know from mainland chinese
disappeared that they can be held
up to several months even more than a
year in these
detention facilities without their
relatives being
noticed i am not aware of any case of
uh people during this protest movement
having been disappeared
in this way what we hear of or what we
know of
is that there have been allegations
earlier one hong kong
bookseller disappeared for several
months in a chinese
detention center and he says he was
kidnapped from hong kong streets
okay this is a brutal toolkit if we
could call that
that the chinese authorities are putting
together how effective
is intimidation right now for the
protesters in hong kong
the effect that intimidation has had so
far
is to stir up people's anger we are
seeing several tactics of
intimidation these border controls that
by the way applied
also to journalists although no
journalist was being detained at the
border
there were just one set the other set is
to ramp
up uh the the the police uh
action and the police brutality also the
weaponry of the police to
crack down harder on protesters what
we're seeing this week this this
siege of the university that that some
protesters had occupied
is of course a tactics that has little
in common with
riot control and more in common with
warfare
or combating terrorists who have
occupied or taken hostage of
a certain place so all these tactics
have not been able
to keep people off the streets and they
have
contributed their part in making the
radicals more radical
and escalating violence so it is quite
unclear what china
is aiming to achieve with these tactics
at the moment
matthias billingham thanks very much for
that report and for
our talk this morning from beijing